[Musique]
bonjour à tous comme chaque semaine je
vous donne rendez vous jeudi pour un
nouveau numéro de fil échos au programme
de cette édition nous parlerons du
budget de l'agglomération
il a été adopté lundi soir et le moteur
est économie 5 millions d'euros était à
trouver des réductions liées à la baisse
des dotations budgétaires
nous parlerons également des chiffres du
chômage en hausse dans les yvelines
vous découvrirez les premières images
des autolib installé au chesnay enfin
dans notre partie magazine reportages
sur la société acs france une entreprise
installée à buc spécialiste des prises
de vue aériennes par rail ou câble elle
travaille pour le cinéma la télévision
ou de grands événements sportifs comme
roland garros enfin dans notre métier de
la semaine plongée au zoo de thoiry avec
un métier au plus près des animaux celui
de curateur pour voir tous ces
reportages rendez vous ce jeudi 30 avril
à 18h30 d'enfiler co